[Music]
on this tuesday night
canada's gdp takes a record plunge
the evidence of how covet 19 infected
our economy
and the promising signs of a recovery
the debate over delaying the second
cobit 19 vaccine dose
it amounts to a human experiment and the
distrust in canada's black community
over the vaccines he said patrick if you
don't take it then i'm not taking it
just shelved why six dr seuss books
won't be published anymore
and rounding up support the politician
steering the campaign to make rodeo
alberta's official sport
national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we all know 2020 was bad
now we have a more accurate picture of
how dismal it was for the economy in
this country
it shrank more last year than it ever
has since the great depression in the
1930s
canada's real gross domestic product
that's our total economic output
adjusted for inflation shrank 5.4
percent in 2020
that's a far greater drop than canada's
banks predicted at the outset of the
pandemic nearly a year ago
there are signs the economy began to
bounce back towards the end of 2020.
real gdp grew by 2.3 percent in the last
quarter
and the forecast for 2021 is looking
brighter
economists expect continued growth in
the months ahead as vaccines roll out
restrictions ease and canada gets back
to business
david aiken has our top story tonight
we had high hopes in january february
and
we're looking at good growth from the
year before and then march hit and it
was just like
an immediate dip across the country in
2020
business owners struggled through a
cycle of lockdowns and re-openings
many survived but many went under
thousands more were forced to lay off
workers in fact
nearly a million and a half canadians
have still not returned
to pre-pandemic work we're about 20 down
in our number of
employees overall ever since statistics
canada started measuring the economy
more than
60 years ago the agency has never had a
year as bad as the last one
the canadian economy contracted shrank
by 5.4 in 2020
versus 2019. oh it does mean a lot i
think
uh part of it is just the severity of it
and getting out of the severe recession
like this
would be challenging but there are signs
that things are looking up for instance
those government transfers like the serb
and the wage subsidy
that helped individual canadians replace
lost income especially among lower
income canadians
so much so that the gap between rich and
poor in canada
got smaller canadians also saved
nearly six times as much of their income
than they did in pre-pandemic times
and that means plenty of pent-up demand
that could help the economy recover
faster and quicker in 2021 and beyond
the key question is whether that bump
that we are going to see would be
sufficient to take us back to
pre-covet levels and that is not clear
still for many the road back will be a
long one
right now we'll actually honestly be
happy if we meet our 2019
levels and that's going to be the first
year for us that we haven't seen even a
small amount of growth year over year
david aiken global news ottawa
the economic recovery is tied to the
vaccine rollout and there are
signs that is picking up steam more than
2 million vaccine doses have now been
administered in canada including
more than 54 000 given today more than
1.4 million canadians have now received
at least one dose
and more than 545 000 canadians are
fully vaccinated with both doses there
is growing momentum behind a plan to
extend the time
between the first and second doses of
the pfizer biontec and moderna vaccines
bc is stretching that time to four
months the aim is to get at least one
dose to more people giving them
at least partial protection now other
provinces are signaling
they could do the same abigail beeman
looks at the reasons and what difference
it could make bc is the only province to
delay a second dose by 16 weeks
but the national advisory committee on
immunization is expected to release
new recommendations on the safe interval
between doses
this week and many other provinces are
excited to follow suit
with the variance of concern out there
this could make a significant difference
for ontario
in reducing hospitalizations and deaths
we are considering that we have looked
at the there's fantastic evidence
this anticipated guidance is a
significant development
and a game changer for pei on the island
it could mean
everyone over 16 gets a first dose by
the end of
june what we're anticipating coming from
nasty is quite a game changer for us
it's unfortunate that bc got out ahead
of a national process
while some are critical of more than
just the timing of bc's move
when you decide to try something new
on an entire population
it amounts to
to a human experiment canada's chief
science advisor says while there is an
argument to be made for a delay up to 56
days between doses based on data
she hasn't seen any data supporting what
she calls a huge
jump to four months i am concerned that
we are confusing the public
with with with just like many different
guidance you know studies here studies
there i think the real debate is
how far can you extend the second dose
that's probably the more contentious
point right now not whether or not you
can extend the second dose i think most
people would say you should you sure can
canada's top doctor said tuesday like
with so many aspects of the pandemic the
science continues to evolve
dr theresa tamm says the question of
intervals between doses will continue to
be monitored
as more evidence comes in abigail beeman
global news
ottawa there is some good news tonight
about canada's vaccine deliveries the
federal government says the first
shipment of the newly approved oxford
astrazeneca vaccine is now on route from
india 500 000 doses are expected to
arrive tomorrow
canada is also set to receive about 445
000 doses this week from pfizer biontec
that makes
this the biggest week yet for vaccine
deliveries to canada
there is some conflicting advice though
over who should be given the astrazeneca
vaccine
late yesterday the federal advisory
group on vaccines said people 65 and
older
should not get the shot because of a
lack of data clinical trials of it
didn't include people over 65
other countries including france
followed that same advice
now as more real-world data emerges the
advice
is changing crystal gomencing explains
with 70 of intensive care units in
france occupied by covet-19 patients
there's a push for more vaccinations
on monday the country's health minister
reversed a previous decision
opening up the age group eligible to
receive the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
to those over 65.
the government spokesperson says there
is now some scientific publication
showing that this vaccine is very
efficient against severe cases of covet
19
as well as in this age group the vaccine
has been a part of the uk's arsenal
since january
the british health secretary highlighted
preliminary data
showing a single dose of oxford
astrozenica
prevented severe infection in those over
70
with a reduction in hospitalizations of
more than 80 percent
these results may also help to explain
why the number of coveted admissions to
intensive care units
among people over 80 in the uk
have dropped to single figures in the
last couple of weeks
canada's national advisory council on
immunizations
is taking the position france previously
held
more data is needed as the initial
clinical trials
didn't include enough older individuals
its recommendation is for the shot to be
offered to essential workers
under the age of 65. but dr teresa tam
says
it's an evolving process don't read
their recommendations
as sort of static they will update as
needed
officials however stress all of the
shots approved
are safe and effective for adults
crystal gamanson global news london
quebec is making vaccinations in the
montreal area a top priority because
cases of the highly contagious variant
first identified in the uk
are on the rise there and the health
minister suggested today restrictions
could be extended or tightened in
montreal
we are afraid that the montreal region
is the calm
before the storm and i think it's
important that you take that into
account
for the announcement that we will make
tomorrow
84 cases of the uk variant have now been
identified in the montreal area
that same variant of concern has been
identified in a recent outbreak in
prince edward island two cases announced
last week involved the b117 variant
analysis is still being done on other
recent cases it's believed most of them
can be linked
pei now has 22 active cases
it is these more transmissible variants
that could drive a third wave of the
pandemic
tonight eric sorenson looks at the
delicate balance as we attempt
to get back to normal there's been a
remarkable downturn in covet 19 cases
since january
if only the trend were continuing it's
not
worldwide case numbers rose last week
for the first time
in seven weeks this is disappointing
but not surprising the world health
organization suggests
covid case numbers have stopped falling
because people are letting their guard
down
governments public health measures are
being eased and
coveted variants are circulating in
canada covet case numbers peaked in
early january around nine thousand cases
per day
and then fell dramatically for six weeks
to about three thousand cases a day in
mid-february
but they have remained stubbornly at
around 3000 a day since then
so what does that mean looking forward
the variance
could cause a spike a third wave or as
spring comes along there could be
a wavelet maybe ripples of new cases and
then as we get into summer
the vaccines could start to bring the
numbers down whatever they are to a more
manageable level
once and for all modeling from simon
fraser university suggests
some provinces could see a sharp rise in
variant cases
if more proactive measures aren't taken
such as testing
tracing and on travel we have to worry
about places where variants of concern
do take off
i think we all share wanting to relax
restrictions
i think we need to be careful around
variants because they are higher
transmission
some experts believe case numbers will
become less relevant than
hospitalizations and deaths
in canada the number of hospitalizations
has been declining steadily since
january and the same for deaths from
over 160 per day in january to an
average of 42 deaths per day now
still tragic but getting better and
early vaccines for the most vulnerable
should improve those numbers in the
months ahead now we know
that vaccination can very effectively
reduce death
and hospitalization so once you have
this intervention
you can now scale back on community
restrictions because we're not having as
many people being admitted to hospital
the covet variants are not going away
but there is optimism that the spread of
vaccines
will overtake the spread of the virus
and make the pandemic manageable by
later this year
eric sorensen global news toronto
the black community in this country is
among the hardest hit by covid19
in the first wave of the pandemic
mortality rates were two times higher in
canadian neighborhoods that have a
higher proportion of racialized
residents yet many members of those
communities aren't jumping at the chance
to get vaccinated
as kayla mclean reports the biggest
barrier is broken trust
yes i just finished doing the moderna
vaccine
it was painless and effortless
patrick shaw got his covet 19 jab to
convince others in his community to do
the same
when i told people to start taking it he
said patrick if you don't take it then
i'm not taking it
shaw is a covid survivor he's also an
outreach worker in northwest toronto
home to the city's largest black
population
many are essential workers living in
close quarters
they're shuttling back and forth in
packed buses but they're also
some of them having multiple jobs to
survive so therefore the transmission of
the virus is
is highly likely overall in toronto nine
percent of the population is black and
yet they account for nearly a quarter of
covet 19 cases
even so toronto's black community has
the highest rates of vaccine hesitancy
30 percent folks understand that
black people have not been treated well
they've been utilized as guinea pigs for
experimentation
in the past and if a government that has
in their opinion mistreated them and not
treated them well
should they listen to them should they
trust them and take that vaccine
racist treatment by the health care
system continues to be a concern today
you should be able to go into an
emergency room a primary care clinic
a hospital a general hospital and
receive the same quality of
care whatever your racial background one
idea
prioritizing vaccines on the basis of
postal codes
this would capture at-risk populations
and save more lives
i'm ready to go anytime you guys are
ready to go shaw says trusted community
ambassadors also need to be included in
every stage of the vaccine rollout
so that the most vulnerable can be
properly informed in a sympathetic way
because what affects one affects all if
you don't take care of it in this
community it's going to spread to other
communities
right kayla mclean global news toronto
six dr seuss books will no longer be
published because of racist and
insensitive imagery dr seuss enterprises
says the books portray people in ways
that they say are hurtful
and wrong among the titles are the first
book written under the pen name for dr
seuss back in 1937 it's called and to
think that i
saw it on mulberry street in it an asian
person is shown wearing a conical hat
holding chopsticks and eating from a
bowl the decision to stop publication
and licensing of this and five other
books was made after months of
discussion
the company says it's committed to
representing and supporting all
communities and families
books by dr seuss have been translated
into multiple languages
as well as into braille and are sold in
more than 100 countries
no more masks no more restrictions
coming up the american states getting
rid
of pandemic protocols
the biden administration signaling a
tougher stance against russia has
announced new sanctions targeting senior
russian officials
over the poisoning of opposition leader
alexei navalny
the sanctions target seven top business
and political figures including russia's
top spy
and 14 entities involved in the
production of chemical and biological
agents
the sanctions prevent the top figures
allied with russian president vladimir
putin from accessing financial and
property assets in the u.s
these are the first sanctions against
russia by the biden administration
russia is threatening to retaliate the
valley is serving a two and a half year
sentence at one of russia's
harshest prison camps today president
biden announced the u.s
expects it will have enough coronavirus
vaccine doses for every adult american
by the end of may and two u.s states are
now taking major steps toward reopening
the governors of texas and mississippi
have announced they are ending their
statewide mass
mandates they are also allowing
businesses to return to full capacity
yesterday texas recorded more than eight
thousand new covid19 cases
family tragedy ahead what happens when
the front line hits home for healthcare
workers
frontline healthcare workers dealing
with covid patients not only worry about
getting sick themselves but
about bringing the virus home they take
extra precautions to minimize the risk
of course but
that is not foolproof karen lieberman
has one woman's heartbreaking story
hi i'm anisa the safety officer safety
specialists work behind the scenes
they support frontline healthcare staff
ensuring they have adequate supplies and
personal protective
equipment you have all the tools that
you guys need and that they're following
safety protocols
we understand a stressful time at the
end of the day want to be safe and go
home to our family safely
for anissa khan until recently that
included distance visits with her
parents
here i am pushing staff at work to be
safe
not to get it and whatever and lo and
behold
my family end up getting it first it was
khan who tested positive for covid19
then her mother then her father fell ill
too
when i went to go visit him he was i
guess
rodney bergeau was rushed to hospital in
early december
he's been there ever since he had a
condition that we call ards or acute
respiratory distress syndrome he had
a really profound needs for oxygen
both parents critically ill one
wouldn't make it it was very difficult
and then the next morning we get the
phone call from the icu physician saying
you know what we have to integrate your
debt burja was unaware his wife marilyn
had passed
more than two weeks later on his 70th
birthday
he needed a tracheotomy losing mom and
then
hanging on desperately that dad won't be
another one gone
fortunately he began improving and dad's
up in the chair looking like a million
dollars
every day khan facetimes her father to
check in
or visit him in person he was starting
to ask about mom how she doing where is
she
the family had to share the
heartbreaking news his wife
did not survive but he is on the road to
recovery
and with the tube removed from his neck
he has his voice back
rodney how are you feeling oh not too
bad
i take it one day at a time for khan
seeing her own family struggle
has been hard i never thought i'd be
here in a million years
and here i am and a reminder to others
instead of snap a finger things can
change very
very quickly for you karen lieberman
global news
toronto
trying to wrangle up support next the
sports debate in alberta
it is a cliche to think alberta is all
about cowboys ranches and oil fields but
there is a push right now to elevate the
status of rodeos to make them
alberta's official sport heather yurix
west explains why
some believe the sport deserves a leg up
nanton alberta's logan bird is a
canadian champion in tie
down roping but right now he can only
compete
in the united states for me at the
professional level
there was nothing since covet hit there
hasn't been one event
every member of the bird family is
heavily involved in rodeo
it's how they make their living so it's
no surprise they fully support
efforts to make rodeo alberta's official
sport
it absolutely should be an official
sport there's lots of people and
i mean a lot that make their living with
rodeo the private member's bill was put
forward by a calgary united conservative
party mla
who was introduced to rodeo culture
later in life
the significance of of this event in
rural
alberta it just was just it was just
amazing it brought people together
muhammad yasin grew up in pakistan but
fell in love with rodeo after coming to
alberta as
a young man designating rodeo as an
official sport would be a mainly
symbolic gesture but it isn't being
welcomed
by everyone rodeo is frankly a very
risky sport that causes intense amounts
of suffering and regularly causes death
alberta shouldn't be considering
celebrating rodeo as the provincial
sport it should be considering banning
this activity
the province has not yet decided when
rodeo events in alberta might be able to
resume
the birds hope it happens soon the
ability to come
home and get back to work more important
than any gesture of goodwill
heather your ex-west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen
we leave you tonight with a bit of news
from music legend dolly parton
she got a dose of her own medicine today
dolly donated 1 million dollars to help
develop the moderna vaccine and
she encouraged others today by changing
the lyrics of one of her songs
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
i'm begging of you please don't hesitate
to anyone feeling a little fearful dolly
says don't be
such a chicken squat her words not mine
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye